yankees 31-22 the blue jays 27 and 26.
and a ground ball weakly hit to short to
second one on to first in time
the blue jays turn the double play now
the reason that king is pitching tonight
is the yankees are trying to maneuver
their pitching for the postseason so
when they start the playoffs they'll
have
extra rest swing and a missed strong
first inning
so king gets two strikeouts in the
inning
hey what these situations this is who
you want at the plate
and he swings and lines one up the
middle base it
center field rounding third scoring is
glabor
holding that second is hits it's a base
hit
and an rbi for geo urscella and the
yankees take a one nothing lead
i think these are going to be big at
bats this week for gary sanchez
and he gets a ground ball beshette
underhand of er
on the first and they will turn the
double play which means if the playoffs
were to begin today the blue jays would
be heading down to tropicana field
the 2-2 to guerrero sky to center field
hicks finds it i think he lost that ball
in the twilight and it's going to drop
judge came over it kicks away from both
of them
and vlady's on his way to third well you
could tell he was having trouble
but then he kind of accelerated into it
and it looked like he had it
but nobody made the play the pitch
struck him out swinging high fastball
so the fly ball that was missed did not
hurt so back to the top of the order and
dj from mayhew who was uh named the
american league player of the week this
week
there's his base hit to right field just
another line drive from dj le mayhew
so stanton is safe and here is voight
with first and third and
two men out top of the third blue jays
down by one shoemaker trying to keep it
there and there's a ball hit on the
ground a third
bobbled by biggio pick it up with time
throw across
perfectly and he retires void
to end the inning boyd hit it hard gave
bisho a lot of extra time to make a good
play
he does too board just went out in the
inning
and here's bo buchet who hit a flyable
to center field his first time up
and the 3-2 and bo hooks it into left
field a base hit
and kirk's gonna go to third and he's
gonna head home
the throw will bounce away and kirk will
score to tie
the game that wasn't even an aggressive
wave by louis that was just a little
with the right hand all right go home
you go home
that's going to get through with the
shift on it'll find a hole
biggio will come in to score the shet
stops at second tay oscar with an rbi
single
and the blue jays have the lead
boy had he caught it that might have
been a strike but he didn't and the blue
jays get the call two balls in one
strike
now he might have called it a strike he
called it for a swing
and gritsy can't believe it richard just
said you got to be kidding me
i don't know what he saw that made him
think it was a swing it was a
ball off the plate to begin with and
gretchen couldn't believe it because
two and one yeah yeah
and again the 2-2 and glitching shoots
it into right field for a base hit
the shed around third the throw is cut
of the blue jays lead 3-1
there have been times where the blue
jays have struggled to score without the
benefit of the home run
but they have strung some hits together
here tonight
that's a fair ball down the left field
line
hernandez in to score richard rounding
third
he will come in to score and it's a five
to one game
the bases are loaded with nobody out
after another walk for vizio
and a base hit into right field for
beshet
kirk in to score everybody else up 90
feet it's six to one
as taos hernandez stands in
a breaking ball there hits a ground ball
down to third the throw coming to the
plate
and not in time gorilla struck out twice
those two strikeouts against michael
king first time facing rawazika
this should be two there's one and
there's two run scores so it's 8-1
toronto but they get two outs with that
ground ball
one out of lady down the left field line
and that's going to go to the fence on a
bounce
the shed will come in to score grichik
around the third and guerrero's got his
third extra base hit of the night
well that's a welcome sign for sure and
it's three balls and two strikes
fly ball to right center field that's
carrying and it's going to go
randall grichik with his first home run
in over
three weeks and the blue jays now lead
10-1
alejandra kirk's had quite a night he's
three for three so
far high fly ball towards the right
field corner
gone can you believe it
he better break out in a smile round in
the bases this time
what a night for alejandro kirk
opposite field home run against the new
york yankees a
forehead knight for alejandro kirk
what a moment now over 5 trying to close
out the yanks
and the 3-2 lines shortly it's a base
hit
down the right field line that could
clear the bases
one run scores two run score
and weight score so it's a three run
double for
talkman and now it's 11-5 toronto
so wilmer font could not get the final
out and the blue jays are
forced to go to shun yamaguchi to try to
nail this down tonight
and he got him yamaguchi strikes out
stanton now they can cheer
and the blue jays have won the opener
for the series 11-5 on an unbelievable
night
for alejandro